T more we don't do the robot
hands these fingers are
leading this elbows drop
dropping and
pushing don't come
sideways you're inside the grip this way
you want to turn his hand this
way you're not going to pull against the
fingers this
way not going this way you turn his
wrist you see okay and you have two
forces one on this
side and one on this side stay there
it's like this
so this these fingers
turning turning this elbow dropping and
the qua turns
everything so don't stay here and go
like
this I do the hand shake I do the hand
shakee with the elbow but the qua moves
It Off
you have Push can
amplifier
CL get rid of that straight
wrist and at what rate at rate the elbow
is dropping
so I'm not going
here it goes there but at the rate the
elbow is dropping which is at the rate
the quaw is moving the
elbow okay let's try get
done okay your elbows dropping at a at a
faster rate than your wrist is
turning okay wait The Claw is ahead you
left your elbow
behind okay don't move stay there don't
move
okay and you still have this flat you
see this this needs to change shape
right that's exactly what we're trying
to lose then the quad turns not your
hand and that completes the drill
no your quaw went ahead of the elbow the
quaw pushes the elbow no no no no you're
pulling on his fingers you have to drop
the elbow by pushing the qua and you got
to get rid of that flat wrist curl your
hand
back okay all that has to happen at an
even rate not one two three
then your to your head of your
wrist you over rotate it can you see all
that yes
okay no you're on pulling on the fingers
now if you move your qua without your
elbow then elbow goes here you see as
the qua moves closer to the Elbow you
leave your elbow in space move your qua
forward that's what you were doing
okay as you start to go one time you
overturned here you just spinning your
hand in here this is not the muscles you
want to use we don't want to use these
muscles
okay he's driving as hard as he can and
this is hard for me to turn do you see
just work cuz he's
not [\h__\h] with you okay so I don't
want that then other times you had
things but you didn't do your wrist you
see and now eventually if he wasn't
pushing if he wasn't pushing you'd see
that you're pulling on the
fingers
so everything has to move at the same
time but they're different rates they
have to stay in harmony so the qua does
move the elbow you see qua moves elbow
not my hand quaw moves the elbow if you
pay attention the elbow's in line with
the shoulder do you see if you move your
hand the elbow's not in the line with
the shoulder it came in and it smashed
here against my body so qua moves the
elbow but what drops the elbow is that
the hand comes up you see if you leave
your if you just go here the elbow stays
higher than the hand so the elbow
doesn't drop so the hand has to come up
but I can't pull against the fingers I
can't go like this so the hand curls
around by the by this moving around this
way and I'm inside now I don't want to
go too far cuz you're going to feel the
fingers again okay so
here qua moves the
elbow when I as I feel the elbow able to
descend I start picking up the Hound
okay the qua is moving the whole elbow
at that time the elbows dropped
underneath and stay inside if you pay
attention close your grip as if my hand
was here you see his fingers make a
circle his fingers make a circle pretend
I'm going to come out and refine that
shape you
see that's what I work
within don't don't pull here don't pull
on the thumb got it I turn the circle
turn the
circle turn the
circle what do I what's the engine of
the rotation the claw it's done that's
all I can move don't start seeking more
you up the finger finger right there
so I feel the circle I move inside the
circle no
here okay try it
again just as there's an under turn so
if you have this flat wrist through the
the whole time there's that would be
under you didn't do it nap okay there's
also over you come like this like what
hand is that okay that's nothing okay
you have L gong that's what you have to
keep so what is it again when you start
to feel the tension in your hand you see
I feel tension in my that's not it I can
only move as I can keep no so here this
won't allow my elbow to drop it's even
you see okay I go I go to here there's
tension all through here that's too far
so you can see the elbow came down
though compared to the hand so I come
back so there's no
tension I don't have it flat the elbows
down Okay so
don't don't look for more in them by
going like
this remember gon is
from I don't want to get into it but
there chakra systems so the one in the
pelvis to the one at your hard diaphragm
okay that's that's get done
so when I hit that area you see that's
where it stops I start going past that
the elbow is now independent of the qua
you see that and I have tension on the
fingers this is this is too high you're
asking for the wrong T remember it
stays no higher than solar flexes or
area that's it that's all there is to it
and then don't
overt just need my elbow to draw that's
it it's all I need okay but don't overdo
it or underdo it okay here we
go so now he's pushing he's pushing with
spinal displacement okay he's pushing
and I do the
movement now he's going to pull so he's
pulling and I will still do the movement
it won't affect I won't feel any of the
fingers cuz I never go here I never go
here okay everything stays inside
boom
boom he can't pull cuz you're turning it
I see oh don't go here turn his hand
turn his hand
watch when I bring it up you start to
pull again leave it
low
push push push
push doesn't chain pull doesn't chain
Push
Pull okay so here we'll pull okay try
it okay so Cheon we'll do the first move
then we'll undo the
claw
here so first move Bo undo the
CLW you down is solar plexus to throat
solar ple to throw
one
boom
Thro notice it shape okay
so this way almost like a
heart
almost okay and the quaw moves it so
here you're
inside okay the Energy's up do you feel
that the energy is not here the energy
is up so if I go in you feel your thumb
the energy is up okay because the
elbow's
down so don't go here
energy is
[Music]
up notice the
shape
here
here do you have a Bend here
no here if you unwind
this and you sit back up and you lower
it it's in
katate you go like
this and you unwind it let go and you
sit back up this is not katate you over
extended
okay so
room up
careful no cuz this is not katate
either too
bad because we're coming from low and
we're going up it should reflect in his
body we're not going out
okay okay so uh this hand
shape you already
know is related
to this area of the body this is where
you
do the cosmic
neutr okay so it's down
here get down down you see to
here this area where this flower shape
fire shape takes form
okay and he'll go to about here where
another shape takes
one which is
Jo okay
so um one
down I take that
shape
here
so you pay attention you let go and I go
back and I come up I bring this shape in
and exactly where that shape
goes if I do everything correctly
I will
keep the katat dir
angle our arm won't
straighten keep the elbow in the same
Bend and if I do that
correctly shape your elbow will stay in
that same Bend you
see
meaning your elbow doesn't go
straight and out so I am moving your
elbow with my
elbow in a big
circle and I have
lower but brought
in see
now I have brought
in but brought
up okay I'm not doing the obvious in and
in okay down and down you see in to go
down and to go up
home always B okay the only way his
elbow goes short and long because your
elbow goes short and long and the only
way your elbow goes short and long is
the quaw is not driving it your wrist is
driving it you're focused on where
they're touching you instead of the
feeling of letting the mo
shape do what they need to do to your
body okay your body mind okay get aren
you
done all right so this region of your
body is associated with water this
region of your body is associated with
fire okay so you're doing the the cosmic
paring and it's in EO
there it
is this is why EO so important
okay your opening